I'll come to this video playing what is
this due by one um okay let's I could go
for this this is the English Defence oh
it's leading to two interesting play
let's see what is doing efore is the
most critical line okay 93 as possible
as well but I don't regard it as being
so dangerous yeah this for instance is
the line that is considered to be quite
quite good for black if it takes it's
not possible that even I can take g2 and
win the rook white is no a substantial
attack yeah this is just blundering
number but in Indians of course you can
always screw up the point is that i have
f aid available for the king I don't
need to play G success and some other
similar type type of lines yeah he's
threatening this intermediate made on f7
so I need to recapture first okay
question is always should I take on c3 i
think i can check take now because of
night a three a bishop a3 is not in the
position anymore then winning this
temple first and then take the rook and
it's it's a whole rook it's not an
exchange or something that you can very
often justify rook is quite quite
something okay he can try to trap on
each one though this is this is clear
question is how to develop him now
2d seven or nine to c 6-r not to
December this looks a bit more bit more
organized if he castles long and move
the night I will take f3 so that's not
so easy I want to Queen a3 is not really
a threat but need to get stuff developed
ok let's let's not think too long here
the the real dangers but you are you
keep on wondering how best to refute
what he is doing and then lose all the
time check maybe it is just get for some
some counter-attack look here intending
to take on c4 if i take on see phone
where you must take care official come
on this is this is just good for me
check it so it's easy to play with the
rook up who came here my queen to d6
95 maybe just here yeah this is it seems
to be good you cannot play 92 here I
just take it yeah but i have i have rook
c8 i have e 5 and yeah let's do a 5m the
auto a to hanging but now g5 i now have
an King g8 if I play Bishop f3 and 95 ok
ok I can take it down
and what now I mean this even Queen g to
come on let's just do that just keep the
peace here I'm a piece up on on
everything top of everything check so
what now Queen Queen everyone okay I
don't know it that everything looks good
queen e 2
yeah 95
many good moves available
jab you again this check
and now maybe a hot night be three maybe
ten o'clock see three roots III and 22
made
still this we had bishop on each one
what is this see not it's not reacting
to that at all i sir am I missing a
trick here I don't even see a check
coming white resigned yeah this is line
is simply simply not possible with
taking on f5 it's it's basically
blundering a route but it's still check
somewhat somewhat complicated in bliss
because you're king of the pic Terriers
on it or won't have one but one of eight
I mean the difference is I mean white
can easily confuse that if you look at
this for example in this position and
five whitey can take this is a
difference because after Bishop g2 yeah
I don't have a half eight well guess
this is very important I must play g6
here and this is of course something
entirely different with Bishop g4
inserted it's it's simply not possible
to take he needs to play a move like we
need to hear on Canada's check and then
we need to this is served the main line
which is normally leading to something
like this bishop here takes takes takes
this is the the main line of this
opening you can get it with g6 or
without g6 depending up on white giving
a check or not and this is about equal
nothing special happening here in the
game at it was just them can look down
maybe I had even quicker ways Jack to
win but this looks very very convincing
yeah yeah maybe I should have calculated
a bit more this this is given by the
computer as completely winning yeah
understandable because now White has
nothing yeah I didn't want to calculate
any of that I think it was ok what I did
always keeps it keeps it a win ok thanks
for watching